- Hey, guys, it's Michelle.
If you're anything like me,
you probably have a hard time
stepping away from life and work
to focus on yourself.
Today, I hope that you take five minutes
and do just that.
This routine is great
for after a stressful day
at work or studying.
Today we're going to target
the lower back and hips,
which hold a lot of tension
when we're under mental stress.
If you want to hold any of the poses
for a little bit longer,
feel free to hit pause
to sink into the pose
a little bit further,
as I'm only demoing each move,
rather than doing a full on routine.
I usually like to hold each
pose for about 60 seconds
to get a full muscular release,
but it's up to you and your body
to decide what's best for you
and what you need on this stressful day.
So here are some great
stretches to de-stress
after a long day.
For the neck stretch,
real your hand over your head
and pull your ear towards your shoulder.
You can reach your other hand
out towards the ground
for a deeper stretch.
Sphinx elongates your lower back,
where you'll feel a lot of tension
if you drive a car or sit in a desk chair
for long periods of time
Sphinx transitions
really nicely into seal,
another lower back stretch that also
elongates your abdominals.
Pigeon is a tough stretch
to get out the kinks in your hips,
which hold a lot of tension under stress.
(gentle electronic music)
Lizard, like pigeon,
stretches out the sides of
your hips and hip flexors.
Side straddle is a little
bit of an advanced pose,
but I encourage you to try it out
because it opens your
inner groin and side body,
which honestly just feels really good
after a long day.
Butterfly is a great stretch
for the inner thighs,
groin, and knees,
and removes fatigue from long hours
of standing and walking.
If you hold the pose long enough,
you'll also start to feel
it in your lower back.
Lastly, child's pose is a calming
and surrendering pose to tie
up your stretches to de-stress.
Thank you guys so much
for watching this video
and for trying out this routine.
If you enjoyed it,
please give it a thumbs up,
and comment below with what workout
you want to see next.
I hope that you feel a
little bit less stressed
and ready to take on your day.
Bye.
(gentle electronic music)